MAGDA JARY: Welcome to the
certification preparation
Professional Security Engineer
and Professional Network
Engineer certification.
My name is Magda, and
I'm the global lead
for the Google Cloud
Certification and Digital
Badges Go-to-Market team.
And joining me today is Cori
Peele, customer engineer
at Google Cloud.
Let's take a look
at our agenda today.
First, we'll review the
certification benefits.
Then we'll review the learning
resources and the Google Cloud
Certification's portfolio.
We'll then talk with Cori
about her certification
and preparation journey.
And then we'll recap with
the additional resources.
So let's get started with
the certification benefits.
First of all, cloud
skills are really
critical to enabling
customer success
and fueling our ecosystem.
The job posting looking
for cloud skills
grew over 40% between
the first quarter of 2019
and the first quarter of 2021.
Secondly, over 90%
of IT leaders expect
to expand cloud services in
the next one to three years,
but over 80% of them identified
a lack of internal skills
and knowledge as the top
barriers to cloud success.
And then lastly, the
Google Cloud skills
are particularly in
high demand, commanding
the top two paying IT
certifications in 2021
in the US.
We also love to hear from
our community about the Cloud
Certification Program impact.
78% of our survey respondents
feel more confident
in their professional future.
82% can prove cloud skills
competency to recruiters.
83% feel that their
resume is more attractive.
And then finally, 85% feel
more confident in cloud skills.
Here are some of
the benefits you
can enjoy by joining the
certification community
and achieving your
certification.
First, you distinguish yourself
with a Google Cloud Certified
badge and a certificate.
You also receive exclusive
Google Cloud Certified swag
for our professional exams.
You can network and exchange
ideas in the Google Cloud
Certified community.
And you also receive special
recognition at select events.
Let's review some of
the learning resources
and our Google Cloud
certifications.
Here are some of
the modalities that
really help us build skills for
the future with Google Cloud
Learning, starting with the
instructor-led format delivered
by our authorized
training partners.
Then we also have a modality
of the on-demand training
so you can learn any time by the
use of the on-demand content.
The third piece is
really the hands-on labs
and is really all about
learning by doing.
So you can practice
there directly
with Google Cloud technologies.
And lastly, our Google
Cloud Certified program
that really provides a framework
and benchmark for success
in core job roles.
Our exams are proficiency
and role-based
and provide you a
benchmark for success.
And let's take a look at the
overall portfolio of our Google
Cloud certifications.
You'll notice we have the exams
at the professional level, as
well as our associate
cloud engineer,
and the very recently
launched cloud digital leader.
This final one is for
the business audience.
Otherwise, our associate
and professional exams
are all job role-based
and really cater
to the technical audience.
Today in our session, we focus
on the professional cloud
security engineer and the
professional cloud network
engineer.
So let's start with the
review of the readiness path
for the networking and
security network engineer role.
You can notice the resources
in the Learn section,
then some hands-on practice
resources with skill badges,
and then some additional
preparation resources.
You can find all
of these resources
on our external
training website.
Specifically reviewing the
professional cloud network
engineer role, let's really
have a better understanding
what this role is really about.
A professional cloud
network engineer
implements and manages network
architectures in Google Cloud.
This individual may work on
networking or cloud teams
with architects who design
cloud infrastructure.
The cloud network engineer uses
the Google Cloud Console and/or
command-line interface
and leverages experience
with network services,
application, and container
networking, hybrid and
multicloud connectivity,
implementing VPCs and security
for established network
architectures to
ensure successful cloud
implementations.
And you can review our exam
page for further details.
On the exam page,
you'll also notice,
what are the core domains
covered by the exam?
And it's all available in the
certification exam guide that's
available on the website.
Likewise, let's review
the preparation path
for the security
engineer certification.
You can note that the
learning resources, trainings,
then in the practice section,
the hands-on labs and skill
badges, some of the
preparation resources,
like sample questions, and then
finally, the certification.
So likewise, who is the
professional security engineer?
This person enables
organizations
to design and implement a secure
infrastructure on Google Cloud.
Through an understanding
of security best practices
and industry security
requirements,
this individual
designs, develops,
and manages a secure
infrastructure leveraging
Google security technologies.
The cloud security professional
should be proficient
in all aspects of
cloud security,
including managing identity
and access management,
defining organizational
structure and policies,
using Google technologies
to provide data protection,
configuring network
security defenses,
collecting and analyzing
Google Cloud logs,
managing incident reports, and
demonstrating an understanding
of regulatory concerns.
All of this
available on our exam
website, including the detailed
domains that the security
engineer exam covers.
So very briefly, a little bit
more information about these
exams.
They are two hours
long, multiple choice,
and multiple select.
There are no prerequisites.
However, we strongly recommend
you have around three years
of industry experience,
including a year, at least,
of hands-on GCP knowledge.
So with this, I'm really
delighted to welcome Cori.
Hello, Cori.
CORI PEELE: Hi, Magda.
How are you today?
MAGDA JARY: Really good.
Great to see you.
So we would love to get
your insights, expertise
on the topic of the security
and network engineer
certifications.
So if you could
start with letting
us know about your role
in some of the projects
you are working on.
CORI PEELE: Yes, thanks.
I'm a customer engineer
with Google Cloud.
And in this role, I'm able
to work with customers
to understand their
business requirements,
some of the things they may
want to do to maybe transform
their industry, and
I work with them
to understand how they
can accomplish some
of those goals using
Google Cloud and parts
of Google Cloud's ecosystem.
And in order to do
this, I need to have
a really good understanding
of what we have
available in terms of features.
But not just that.
It's really focusing on, how
do you solve these business
problems with the right
amount of emphasis
on performance for the right
price at the right time?
And by doing this with
some of my customers--
and some of you may be seeing
some of them speak during
Google Next--
we are able to accomplish
really meaningful and impactful
accomplishments, not
just for the customer,
but also for the
users they serve.
And in that way, they
all have a bit of a focus
on improving our overall
experience in the world today.
So it's extremely rewarding.
MAGDA JARY: That's
great to hear.
Thank you, Cori.
So please tell us about your
certification preparation
experience.
CORI PEELE: Yes.
So in my case, I had
several certifications.
However, I was focusing
on how to study
where I'm optimizing my time.
Because when you think about
the certification journeys
and you look at the
exam guides, you
will see that there are
certain common recommendations
across networking and security.
So having a really
solid understanding
of the foundational
infrastructure
components of Google Cloud
will be the first thing.
And so we have the ability to
use instructor-led training
or on-demand training through
Pluralsight or Coursera.
So I mapped out the
courses, and I also
leveraged the
certification paths
that have been outlined by
our certification leads.
And so by doing this, I was
able to go through the training
in terms of on-demand training.
I had also mapped
out the questions
that were maybe
giving me some trouble
when I took the practice exam.
And this is extremely useful,
because the Google Cloud
practice exam gives you not
only an explanation regarding
each answer, but it gives
you links to resources
for further information.
So after doing
that practice exam
and understanding that
there are other areas
to focus on a bit more, I
was able to really research
and make sure I had a solid
understanding of those topics,
as well.
I also participated in community
activities, where several of us
are embarking on a
certification journey together.
And this helps, because you're
able to ask questions and also
benefit from
communicating with others.
And so in this case,
once I felt comfortable
that I was able to answer
the questions across all
of the sections
of the exam guide,
then I registered for the
exam and I was able to pass.
So I'm very fortunate to
have several certifications,
including the security
and networking engineer
certifications.
MAGDA JARY: Wonderful,
and congratulations, Cori.
CORI PEELE: Thanks.
MAGDA JARY: So how
would you encourage
someone brand new to the
security or network engineering
area to set a goal of
achieving a certification?
CORI PEELE: Yes, I would really
encourage you to think about
how this benefits your
day-to-day activities,
in addition to how it may impact
your company and your growth
in your organization as a whole.
The things you are doing
today in your environment
might be focused on maybe a
couple of different patterns
and a few different
architectures,
based on what you have in
your environment today.
However, in order to
really be prepared
for different types
of challenges,
and to really have a
solid understanding of how
you can apply these
types of technologies
to other business problems,
it's important to have
a very detailed understanding
and a broad understanding
of a lot of the topics that
are covered in the exam.
And so I really would
encourage you to think
about achieving certification.
Think about planning-- and
I would say think of it
in terms of maybe in 12
weeks, so within one quarter.
You may start your studying in
the beginning of the quarter
and then plan to have an
exam taken towards the end.
So that way, you're
able to incorporate
studying for the exam with
all the other things you're
probably doing at the same time.
And so with that
type of structure,
it's fairly reasonable
for you to be
able to really have
that goal established
and then also achieve the goal.
And don't worry if you
don't pass the first time.
You have the ability
to retake the exam.
So again, the focus
on establishing
that type of target goal, and
then planning your schedule
accordingly so you can
meet that timeline.
MAGDA JARY: Thank you, and
thank you for all the tips.
Cori, could you review some of
the synergies between security
and networking in Google Cloud?
CORI PEELE: Yes, and there
are a lot of synergies.
And actually, when you think
about what the cloud is,
we are thinking about the
resources that are networked.
And so network security
is very important.
And you will find that there
are networking and security
topics on both exams.
So one really important
perspective we have at Google
is to think about
a zero-trust model.
We've published a white
paper called Beyond Corp.
And this is just a
different way of thinking
about managing security and
network security for those who
are used to the world where
you have a demilitarized zone,
and you're allowing
communications across the board
as soon as someone
has permission
to get into that perimeter.
Well, with zero
trust, this means
that even though you may
be in the same network,
you do not have access.
So this is, again, nothing--
no access unless
you are granted that
by a policy explicitly
or something where
you are inheriting it.
So being able to apply
these types of principles
across multiple products in the
security and networking space
will be really important.
Also, it's important to
think about how we approach
open-source software security.
So we have a lot of
different mechanisms
to plan how we are
managing development
and what happens from a
development standpoint.
But also, when you're
doing additional builds,
there are many other
types of approaches.
And so this is something that
you want to really think about,
because the impact of
leveraging open source,
where potentially-- this
doesn't happen that often.
But it has happened where
there may be a bad actor.
And so how do you prevent that
from impacting your business?
So making sure you
have enough awareness
of a lot of the latest practices
and demonstrating competency
to really plan to protect your
organization is important.
Again, protecting
against ransomware.
Ransomware is a problem our
world is dealing with now
and it seems to
be getting worse.
However, we have
tools and products
and processes to help protect
against ransomware and other
types of attacks.
So having this type
of knowledge lets
you understand what you may do
on the networking side in terms
of how you're protecting
from that standpoint,
but then also from a security.
And then when people think about
cybersecurity in general, how
do you really approach this?
And so we have, again, processes
and tools and product offerings
to assist with that.
One major change in
the past several years
has been the shift
from just working
with data centers that
are owned by a company
to a cloud infrastructure.
And then now you actually
have several approaches
where you're thinking about
multicloud and hybrid cloud.
So your approach to security
across all of these boundaries,
and then also the
way you approach it--
let's say if you were maybe
monetizing some offerings,
or doing joint ventures and
you have a different definition
of what these boundaries
actually are--
this becomes something
that can appear
to be fairly complicated.
However, if you are
able to leverage
some of the recommendations
and best practices
from Google Cloud, you'll have
an understanding of the way
to approach this so that your
company and organization will
be able to be really flexible as
different demands and business
models emerge in the future.
And then really thinking about
cybersecurity and resilience,
cyber-resilience is
extremely important.
And when you are thinking about
the broad spectrum of security
and networking and how
it's addressed together,
it's really providing
you with the capabilities
to address these
real-world problems.
So I really recommend
anyone who--
again, if you already
have a certification,
or maybe you're someone who's a
manager of people who are doing
more of the hands-on
tasks, it's still
useful to think about
getting these certifications,
because these
certifications focus on,
how do you approach the design
to meet a certain business need
or to address certain problems?
And it's not focused
on just tasks.
So by having a really
great understanding
of how you approach the design
of security and networking
will really be very beneficial.
So yeah, and Magda, thanks for
asking some of these questions.
This is a really
important topic.
And I really hope that we have
a lot more of our customers
and other stakeholders consider
taking the certification exam.
MAGDA JARY: Super helpful.
Thank you so much, Cori.
Great insights.
And thank you so
much for your time.
And with this, we
are going to wrap up
with additional resources.
So if you do want to start
or continue your readiness
journey in the networking
and security area,
here is your spot.
So we are very excited to
introduce the Google Cloud
Skills Boost, our new
destination for Google Cloud
Learning, with over 700 labs,
courses, and certification
preparation resources.
And to help you build
the technical skills
that you and your teams need,
we are opening up access
to Google Cloud Learning
for a month at no cost.
So just visit
g.co/cloud/freetraining.
And thank you so much
for your time today.
We hope you enjoyed the session
and learned something new.
Bye-bye.